each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's my pleasure to welcome our eager
Finkel from the University of Toronto
who is a visiting the next two days and
he's worked on software model checking
something near and dear to many of our
hearts and he's going to tell us about
his thesis work on a construction
analysis and understanding of sulfur
models hello so the main focus of my
research has been on developing
techniques to help software engineers
build more reliable and dependable
software systems and I believe that we
can do it by giving software engineers
rather tools tools it gives them more
confidence than testing alone while
remaining easy to use so I think that
this tool should be fully automatic they
should be reasonably easy to use the
existing software engineers can apply
them effectively they should come with
some kind of guarantees and hopefully
some guarantees that we can measure and
come with guidelines and methodologies
to apply them effectively and finally
they should be applicable to real
software systems because that's where
they needed the most so during my
studies at University of Toronto I
worked at a variety of projects in this
general area of automated reasoning some
of the projects like this multivariate
model checking a more exploratory in
nature and the idea was there to try and
look how we can extend the analysis to
earl estate earlier stages of the design
process where we have to deal with
partial information and potential even
inconsistent information about the
system ability some other projects like
understanding counter examples and
vacuity detection deal more with
usability issues surrounding automated
analysis so an understanding counter
examples we looked at giving user a
better support to understand the result
of a model checker and understand the
counter examples that are generated and
then vacuity detection we looked at how
can we improve the trust in
automated analysis in particular in
checking whether every part of a formula
is relevant for the particular analysis
otherwise the formula satisfied
vacuously which probably indicates some
kind of modeling problem and in the
temporal logic theory checking project I
looked at how can we use the same mobile
check-in technology to try and discover
properties of a model instead of charge
them whether they satisfy them and what
we'll be talking about today is my
latest project which is a software model
checking it basically and tries to apply
model checking techniques to analysis of
software programs now let me start with
just the quick overview of what a fine
estate bubble checking it basically we
start with some software hardware defect
and the correctness property and we want
to know whether the artifact is correct
with respect to this property we need to
extract define it's the model of the
artifact translate the correctness
property into temporal logic the student
given to model checker which
automatically decide whether their
artifact is correct or not outputs yes
or no and if the answer is no it can
potentially produce a country so what we
want to do is we want to apply this
model checker to software programs of
course the problem is that programs are
not finite state they use integer
variables recursion and bound the data
structures and all of these features
which make them infinite state and
really hard tunnel is so we can just
take a program fit it into a model
checker and expect to get an answer so
what we need is some kind of an
obstruction need to somehow reduce the
program into finite model which is small
enough to be to analyze but still reach
enough to give conclusive results now of
course this doesn't solve any problem
yet because we now have two problems we
need to know how to check the
abstraction but we also need to know how
to construct it and this is not a
trivial task and the idea is that we can
try and build this abstraction
iteratively and one is known as a
counterexample guided abstraction
refinement framer OC curve for sure
the devices framework works is we start
with the program and safety property
trying to check whether some error state
of a program is unreachable we build an
initial abstraction of the program we
are approximated by a bullet model that
the model checker can understand and
then use the model checker to check our
property if the result is yes then we
know that error is unreachable in the
blue line model and since it's another
approximation it's unreachable in the
program and so we can stop otherwise
it's answer is no we get an abstract
counter example which is an execution of
this bull and models at least in our
state we can then check whether it
corresponds to an execution of a
complete program by simulating it
however the program in trying to see if
it's a valid execution if that works
well we just found an erroneous
execution we can report it to the user
otherwise there was some reason why we
have an execution in this abstract model
which is not part of an execution of a
program and we can use this information
to refine our obstruction and then
repeat this processing so just to give
you a quick example of how it works
click here we have a program and we want
to know whether error is reachable and
the first step is we build our
obstruction which initially just
contains the control flow statements of
the program with everything else
obstructed away so in particular is a
start here indicate that the condition
of the wire loop is obstructed the way
and no longer known we then build a blue
line of approximation of this which in
this case is just the control flow graph
of the program and check whether line 5
he responds to their statement is
reachable in it now here until you to
see that it's reachable and the model
checker will produce this counter
example showing home we're now going
back to our program and try and see
whether this counter example is also
feasible execution of the concrete
program does the first step is perfectly
fine we can go from one to two
now the second step is a little bit
problematic according to this counter
example to get too narrow we have to go
from line to 294 which means we need to
skip this one why alarm right look but
if you look at what happens in the
program after we do the first line y is
equals to 2 and therefore we have to
enter the right look but according to
our counter example we have to skip it
which is not possible and the reason why
we have this execution in our abstract
model is because it doesn't keep track
of the condition of the wire loop so
this is what we need to do in order to
refine abstraction we need to add this
condition interop strict program so we
now go and repeat this process again and
this time the abstraction that we get
also has a control flow statement but it
also has a boolean variable B that keeps
track of this condition that we would
rather y is less than or equal into and
for every statement we have to figure
out what does the statement due to this
condition does the first statement sets
it to true there while can loop
condition just depends on it this
statement basically says that if I was
less than two before we subtract one
then it remains less than to offer but
if Y was not less than two before we
subtract one and we don't know one
happens to it after which is indicated
here by this stop and there's nothing
that we can say about this condition so
it remains unknown and that's it so
again we will doubt over approximation
and now here it's very easy to see that
the line 5 is corresponds dinner is
unreachable and basically and what we
can see from this of approximation and
that's the only way to get to know is if
we ever get to what line to that
corresponds to the beginning of the wire
loop with a loop condition being false
but according to our obstruction
initially the loop condition is true and
then it remains through with Sinha loop
and therefore will never get to zero
state
so now let's go back and try and look
again at what was going on so we had
this obstruction which is inherently a
partial model it describes some of the
information that we know about the
program and it hides some of the other
information so in particular this star
here means that the condition is unknown
been obstructed away and we no longer
know what it is and if you look at the
model that we use in mobile checking
well it's an over approximation in a
sense that the same condition the one
that corresponds to line two is modeled
as a non-deterministic choice which
basically says we assume that either we
enter the loop at this point over exit
Zulu so this means that this model has
strictly more behaviors than our
abstract program and therefore if we
prove that something is unreachable in
this model it's really unreachable but
if we prove that something is reachable
well it doesn't actually mean it does
this process an interesting limitation
to the seagram work the first of all
because we're over approximate if the
model checker says yes well we can trust
this result but the model checker is
biased to trying to prove the timing is
unreachable because it only sees an over
approximated model if the answer is no
well then we need to validate the sensor
we can trust it and in order to do this
we need a counter example which is
linear so that we could simulate it and
finite so that the simulation stops and
that means that this whole framework is
limited to safety properties because
this is the only properties that have
finite and linear countering them and
all of this problem is caused by the
fact that we're using a normal model
checker and we try to over approximate
arm abstract models in order to do so
let me just show you a few examples of
how over approximation causes us to do
more refinements and strictly necessary
to solve the problem so here is a simple
program and just been located it's easy
to see that air
ritual here is it's obstruction is
a subtraction doesn't even have any
predicate but it's still enough to show
that well yet error is still ritual and
this is a corresponding over
approximation where instead of saying
that this condition is unknown be
treated as a non-deterministic choice
and on this other approximations only
thing we can say is that polar is
possibly reachable we're not sure when
they counter example to validate the
star meant that the condition is unknown
none that means there is a non do that
means that there's some non
deterministic choice controlled by
something outside of the program the
star would correspond to an internal non
determinate and none that would
correspond to external auditor
well here
it's not referring to here it's
referring to can we using this conclude
that error is reachable anger
well it's possible because it's a nova
approximation and whenever we detect
that error is reachable in an over
approximation we have to say possibly we
need to do Morrison and in this case you
can eyeball it and say you know there's
a simple reason when the second column
is because there's enough information
here to say that there is definitely
region because because here I when I
analyze this program let's not an over
approximation that's an obstruction so
from it I can conclude that there is
rich
done abstraction is something that
describes some of the information that
we know about the program and doesn't
describe some odd rain so here this is
an abstraction it tells me exactly what
they know about the program I know its
control flow graph I know that this
condition is something I just don't know
what exactly did
but I'm going to do I'm going to give
more more more example so when I say
obstruction I mean a bulan program with
star Singh who are start means it's an
unknown condition
r
who
correct more possible
well in an obstruction you can say
whether an execution depends on
something to be obstructed to end up so
here i can say that when you go from one
to two that's a complete execution of
the program it doesn't depend on
anything that I've obstructed the way
whether i go from one to two to three
all that depends on start because the
only way i can get two threes a star has
to be true it depends on information
that I've removed so I cannot say
conclusive whereas here because you have
the snow and determinism you can tell
you don't know whether this non
determinism is an external one or an
internal one is going to be next example
right too but if you just follow the
standard approach worry i have an over
approximation a check whether error is
reachable the answer is yes it's ritual
you can't get trusted you need to
counter example to validate so a counter
example that you can get could be this
one that's a perfectly valid country go
but this counter example is not a
feasible counter for execution of this
program which means if you get this
counter example you'll need to go and do
an additional refinements of add more
predicate also there is enough
information in the subscription to
conclude the errors which
but here while you're going to get a
counterexample but you should get a
counterexample which will tell you you
go from one to somewhere in here not
sure where and then definitely so you
don't get a complete counterexample but
you get enough information to prove the
very good here is a another example so
here now this complete program also has
its non deterministic traces which would
be used to model a choice that depends
on maybe a user input or chose it
depends on some external resources which
we which we don't want to model and so
if we look at this program it's clear
that error is reachable in right if we
build its abstraction well when we
abstract we can still keep the fact that
there is a non-deterministic choice here
in here and this condition is not
obstructed away if we don't have those
predicates but there's still enough
information here to prove that error is
reachable don't know one of them
you can think of this error label as
calling an error function so we're
checking put it another function can be
hope so I don't know which one but I
know that well this is an external
choice it means whenever and execute the
program a user can input something to
force the program into here and then
either this condition is true and I'll
get to an error or it's false and then
something can again force the program to
get to nurse so anyway you look at it
the error is rich if you build a nova
approximation well now we can tell the
difference between a non-deterministic
choice which is really an external trace
and a non-deterministic trace which is
part of our overall proximate and again
is an arrow reachable here well possibly
we need account your example in order to
validate we get the shirt discounter
example which is typically what we get
from auto tracker and this particular
execution is again not a feasible
execution of this program which means
this will cause us to add more
predicates to try to refine our
abstraction to remove this country
yes
yes so so the definition that are at
least intuitive of the definition of
what does error reachable means in here
is error is reachable in here if for all
concrete programs that could have been
obstructed to this one error is ritual
you can
so no matter how star actually is
resolved by the program no matter what
condition in it error is still rich yeah
so there exists that there exists a
sequence of choices the user can make so
that from the abstraction we can
conclude the program will get to nurse
um
but long the
none that would mean
it depends how you're funny but one is
angelic one is demonic one is internal
one of external certified sewn on this
is demonic and
because it always can get it always
and in star
it doesn't matter how you open it
I'm sorry
a
except I'm looking at it from pointing
to you whether error is reachable all
right then you look at it from the point
of view of whether a program is correct
so when they say yes it means the
program is actually melts correct
original then again the changes that
the point of view of what angelic isn't
worth the money
does the program is a refinement of the
obstruction
now the over approximation would be an
obstruction call a refinement of that
part because you can look at this as
again as a program that has everything
known is just some choices are not made
by the program by the made by some
external t
so for example it could have been that
my program looked like this initial and
this is what it got infected
at our
Oh partial fun yeah
or some kind of proof that tells you
that there exists
so the problem that this overbrook
summation call this is that it causes a
loss of information that we have an
abstract programs it makes the analysis
someone easier when we want to prove
that a probability is true that error is
unreachable but eat when the property is
actually false and there is reachable
and it bleeds don't necessary
refinements and it makes it harder to
detect bugs because over approximation
introduces more serious behavior but we
could have avoided this problem if we
would model abstract programs by partial
models and started fondling them by bull
animals and extend our model checking to
such bonds and in fact they've been
quite a lot of work on reasoning about
partial models how to represent them and
how to analyze them and basically
there's a number of different modeling
formalism such as model transition
systems mix transition systems three
values Kripke structures and so on has
been proposed to capture a partial model
and then each side thing comes with a
partial model checking algorithm that
takes a temporal property not
necessarily safety properly but maybe an
arbitrary CTL property and one of these
structures and can give you one of four
possible answers eyes are true
indicating that there is enough
information in the model to verify the
property false meaning that there is
enough information in the model to
refute the property unknown meaning that
there is not enough information the
model is too partial to claim either way
and sometimes you can even get an
inconsistent answer when there's some
kind of inconsistency in your partial
model and you can boast prove and
disprove your property now this last
part is not really relevant for this
talk because here I'll assume that we'll
always derive our partial model from a
concurrent program which guarantees that
this model is always consistent by
construction so now work right so this
partial models can actually be related
based on how well they capture this
partial information and the basic idea
is that in order to represent that the
model is partial we need to have two
kinds of print
sessions may transitions that indicate
what's possible and mass transitions it
indicates what's necessary if we also
have a consistency requirement that
every mass transition is may transition
and we get what's known as model
transition systems and equivalently we
can get exactly the same type of models
if we take Kripke structures and extend
them to three valued cleaning logic if
we drop this requirement of consistency
and we get mixed transition systems and
in this logical side of things at
corresponds to taking Kripke structures
and extending them to form a lead
Belknap logic if we go further and
introduce a hyper must transition the
transitions that go two sets of states
then we get generalized transition
systems and we can go further and even
use three automata to represent this
partial system and each time we go down
we can capture this partiality with
system more precise there's a system
that we actually use an hour ours is
bounded Kripke structures and the reason
is that on one hand they support
monotonic obstruction refinement it
means whenever you refine this side
Kripke structure you get something which
is strictly and more precise which is
not true about model of three valid
creepiest factories and at the same time
they're truly easy to analyze which is
not true about this structure so what is
bound up logic and the bounder Kripke
structures well a bound up logic is just
an extension of boolean logic of true
and false with two additional values the
bottom value that corresponds to unknown
and the top value that corresponds to
inconsistent now if we want to compute
the reason with this project it's
convenient to turn it around so is it
true is at the top and falses at the
bottom and then conjunction and
disjunction just correspond to meet and
join in this project and negation and is
just an iteration de turns it upside up
there for example are true and unknown
according to the rules would give us a
known
and true unknown would give us room so
well no critical structures adjust
traditional kirkby structures extended
to this logic which means that for
positions can take one of these three
values as a true/false unknown the here
for example we have a state where he is
true and Q is false and another state
where P is true and Q is a node and
transitions can also take and values
from the logics where top transition
correspond to a necessary behavior
bottom transition correspond to a
possibility possible behavior through
transitions correspond to something
which is both necessary and possible and
false transitions correspond to
impossible behaviors and they're not
shown in the structure the Z's easiest
way to understand to try and get
intuition to what the structure means is
to look to what Buland structures that
corresponds to and it corresponds to a
blue line structure which has at least
all of the necessary transitions which
resistant and its most all of the
possible transition so this bound of
Kripke structure represents the set of
purchased Bullen Kripke structures that
lie between this one and this one so
that's in what sense it represents
partial information it represents one of
the structures but we don't know which
one and when we reason about this
structure it's like reasoning about all
of these things at the same time so
possible
that's the necessary it's like a must
that's like ma and that's like a truth
which is ma spin me because we do not
require that every mosque is a mate
since that leads to day to being able to
represent information multi-phase so you
have three choices may must and mayhem
okay so this kind of means we have is
representing something that has a
non-deterministic choice between setting
Peter false and Q default or setting p2
true and if you happen to take this step
that sets Peter true then we do not know
whether Q will be true or false so
what's now a non-deterministic choice
between sending Peter false and Q
defaults of setting Peter true and
something happens to you and what's
unknown is when we exist choice what
will happen to you whether it will be
true
and that would mean there is a
non-deterministic trees and inside an
external choice that somebody else makes
that you have two actions and you have a
non-deterministic choice between them
and choices made not by the program but
by some external
well i'm slightly abusing plantation
here so here i have the state where p is
true and there's no value for cute so
really i have to represent this using
two systems one where p is true and Q is
true and one word peace grew and true
and Q is false and say that what is
necessary is that it's one of this
not nothing that this is a boolean model
but the list information is that he has
to become true and I don't know what
happens to you and this is the possible
choices you could become true you could
become home
so there's a relation between states so
depends as much transitional a
traditional
uh
the damask transition process what's
necessary the green transitions tells us
what's possible if we start randomly
changing things you may create a system
that says it's necessary for me to
become true and it's not possible for me
to become true right because if we say
remove this green transition then it's
like saying it's not possible for me to
become true because the sound of our
possible next state does not include the
state where they stood there for just
trying to represent something by it's
over and under refrigeration we can
potentially create something which has
an empty intersection inconsistencies
does this won't happen in this case
because we're going to start to the
concrete program and derive its partial
representation so we by construction
guaranteed that the result distances
ok
and that they are represented together
to represent that it's necessary zat one
of them escaped as possible also means
that possibly none of them are out here
this necessary ensures that one of the
mistake so another way to look at it if
you want to use hybrid transitions you'd
say this blue transition really
corresponds to a hyper mass trans issues
to this them
of
unknown
inconsistent
but
let think okay so this is this is what
is called them Belknap logic and this is
the information ordering so as you go up
you have more and more information so
you have true and false that have the
same amount of information an income
verbal if you know true you know truth
you know fall Cena false all you can
note bottom means lack of in for me
that's why it's at the bottom here and
tall means that you have you know both
true and false it information overload
but but when I want to reason about it I
want to know what does and the Norman
actually if we just turn it this way and
we can take meat and join of the status
as our engine ours and they will
correspond to our intuitive notion of
what they should write like a true
unknown all that should be true or if we
do false i know well that should be
unknown and stuff
and this is known as the truce order of
that is so this is how to its
computational recorder and we want to
compute iterations and this is its
information earlier when we want to know
how much information I put this
precision of the obstruction means you
have the most definite value ordering
out to do we have an inconsistent
results
so then I think about this bounder
Kripke structures is that the very easy
to check temporal probabilities over
them and in particular we keep semantics
of all of the temporal operators as
usual but we interpret all of the
propositional connectives in belknap
logic there for example the semantics of
exp remains the same it basically says
it's a disjunction over all states of
the value of a transition to that state
and the value of P in that state but now
conjunction and disjunction I interpret
it in this bowl approach so for example
if we'll check here in this state what's
the value of e xq state the series we're
going to get that the result is unknown
and that's because the only place where
you can get to state where Q is true is
through an unknown transition we can do
the same for other free Oh father
appropriate and actually my work that
I've done on multi logic model checking
is in part implementation of this idea
in a model checker which we called
culture so what this talk is about and
about a different model checker called
Yasim that stands for yet another
software model checker and whose goal is
to try and combine the seeker framework
with KY checks ability to reason about
this partial model and so basically we
want to get a framework it looks kind of
like the normal cigarette from ur we
want to keep the same notion of
obstruction because abstract programs
already have this partial information we
need to give them semantics so that we
can translate them into gamma probe
constructors who would then be able to
take an arbitrary temporal property and
new sky check to check whether it's true
or false if it's either true or false oh
then we can stop otherwise we'll get
that the result is unknown and we'll
need to do something to be able to
refine our obstruction and for this
process to get in before I'll talk about
this I want to show you just a quick
demo of the tool on the example that I
showed you
so here is the first thing uncle
so this is the program that we saw
before where we have this if statement
it doesn't actually do anything and we
get to a nurse and so what we expect if
we check whether is reachable we should
be able to do it without needing any
predicate and so to do this we're on yes
sir and this is our property whether an
error state is reachable on this program
and after a little bit it comes back
with saying well the properties that you
track this true and I didn't need any
predicate student so this is just a very
simple example here is a more
interesting one so here we have a
program that has some non deterministic
choices also makes some and computation
with action y which looks fairly
complicated and we want to know whether
it can reach it it can reach an error
label so whether it can call the error
for the process is a complete program a
complete program can never have star
it does it just that it will not be a
complete purpose because it would be an
abstraction of something that's why you
have starved
so none that would correspond to some
external choice that maybe instead yeah
not
yes
if you look at this program it may look
at somewhat complicated because of all
of the things but actually we can check
we can prove that error is reachable
without needing any predicate at all
gasps from the control flow structure of
this again if we run yes I'm on this
example quickly comes back and says yep
error is reachable the result is true no
predicate said it does but noted but the
basic reasoning if you look through it
well at you can force you can make this
choice you can always force the program
to get to an error state using film
deterministic choices no matter how this
other conditions obstructed in all ways
abstract counterexample hood victory or
partial explanation and then you would
need to simulate it over the program to
get that can create I can create culture
because you interested in an execution
of the concrete program anyways that
gets dinner and then they can create
program it has to be a trace
are you
that's what you look like
you can take any one of this pass and
then you may pick an invisible one and
so instead you could try and run your
visibility analysis but restricted to
that face
so here's just one more example
is the program that has some kind of
while loop was unknown determined as
minute and well one of the things we can
do is we can check whether this program
terminates which is not really
interesting because basically it's as
well I need to know that the answer loop
and actually little can terminate in one
step so that's a proof that tells us
that there existed terminating
aggravation but what's more interesting
is we can also check whether it's
possible for this program to not
terminate whether this loop has non
terminating execution and we do it by
asking whether there exists an infinite
execution that never gets to the last
program statement and again run it we
get that yeah that's true the only thing
that we needed to know is whether the
loop condition is true and basically the
explanation here would go as well you
can get inside this loop and then you
can always pick this branch of an if
increment Y and always stained it this
is an example of a probability which is
not a safety problem it doesn't have a
finite linear country
so what I'm going to do in the rest of
the talk is show how we go from this
abstract programs to build up your
structures talk about how we do
abstraction refinement in this case how
this new framework can be exploited show
some experimental results then conclude
and talk about future so in order to
interpret this abstract statement we
need to give them some kind of
transition system semantics and the
typical view is to do an over
approximating Simon so here we'll start
with some statement here is it's
obstruction using two predicates and to
get an over approximation we can
intuitively we have to treat this star
as a non-deterministic choice just build
a transition system corresponding to
this day so for in particular here we
have this non-deterministic choice which
basically says that when be one is false
and run with as a statement we don't
know what everyone will be true or
whether it will befall that's our over
approximating semantics of the state
then we don't know and we model it by
saying star means non-deterministic
different poles which gives us a good
lens system where but we can also build
an under proximity semantics from the
same obstruction and intuitively what we
would do here is we treat star as just
an extra value that we have that we can
assign to a variable and just propagated
throughout your program and make sure we
never make any decisions that depend on
it going so what will get scared in the
same state well when V 1 is false and
between stru and we run the statement
well the one going to get started but
bit we're going to remain then change
its going to remain if we happen to run
the statement in a state where we didn't
even know what the value of predicates
d1 is well we will just stay in the same
place because be two would still remain
true and the one would still remain
store so this would be our under
approximating semantics corresponding to
the substrate stick
it refines the abstract program and is
independent of the computer
so I was using this internal and
external non-determinism just as an
intuition because I but
and
yes
I don't know made it no that's one of
the connections become a virgin but
in some sense so you want to say that
you do with a tail you could say one
agent controls one set of persons and
other agent controls others are the
faces and then you want to know whether
one can force which would would be very
similar now what's the exact connection
whether they're exactly the same or
there is some difference in terms of
what you can prove in what you can out
propose the complexity of proving it
that I don't know the thing during its
radial would be more precise but also
yes
which doesn't doesn't have any logical
minute to just start right then which we
just propagate around in our program and
make sure a known conditional sentence
that means any execution that I have in
fear can be necessarily mimicked by an
execution in the abstraction and can be
mimicked by an execution in the computer
because under approximation none of this
stuff still dependent but because we
introduced arson here I may not be able
to give you an exact agree I may not
tell you what the value of this
predicate is I'll tell you that there is
existing execution where you get to the
state and predicates will have some
value and then the rest of the execution
does not depend on it for greater than
maybe it gets a value none
but you would need to drive them over
and what we're doing is we effectively
tracking them by interpreting everything
in the Spelman project so you talk
transitions with logical values and not
in effect is the same as parking thing
I probably would be the same as then in
fact the implementation that we do we
reduce everything to google and systems
and use boolean logic to do all of the
underlying business and hug that maybe
and if you ignore how we got there and
just looking the hope of convincing that
we can interpret this in an over
approximating fashion which fits star is
non-deterministic choice anything
happens and in an under approximating
fashion which basically says there is an
extra value let's see what we can we do
without depending on and what we work is
what we call exact semantics in the
sense that they combine this over and
under approximation they neither over no
under using this I'm bound of crypto
structures and the basic idea is that
first of all instead of star we're going
to use our value bottom that represents
a known and then for transitions we're
going to say transition is possible if
it only appears in the over
approximation transition is necessary if
it only appears in the under
approximation and the transition is true
if it appears both in over and under
permission so now this barner Kripke
structure is an exact representation of
the substrate statement in a sensor that
has all of the same information that you
have inside the state he knows that
certain things will happen because of
this true transition he knows that
certain things are necessary because of
some necessary transitions and certain
things are not known like we don't know
when we execute a statement from here
what will happen to be one but we still
know that v2 is unchanged so we still
have that information here
with them
why
ok than them
you try and the transition that you put
should not depend on star
fault then you could not then you would
not be able to say whether this
transition happens or doesn't happen for
example say you have beef star and you
have to brunch now you don't know what
the start is start would have been a
constant could have been true then only
one branch would really happen it could
have been false and so that only the
other branch could have happened and so
in another approximation you just say I
yeah I richest state where I lost all
information
three
yes and you typically look for this kind
of case where a green arrows tell you
there's some split but blue error still
tell you and something you can still
known so if we apply this to every
statement in the program we get a valid
Kripke structure that corresponds to the
full program to hear how it looks like
for this example that we so before and
again the kissing carries this is to
know that this bounder Kripke structure
represents exactly all of the
information we have in this inspection
so this non-deterministic choice here is
modeled by a non-deterministic choice
between two through transitions the
program can non deterministically go
here or here and as this unknown
condition is modeled by
non-deterministic choice between two
unknown transition meaning that while
here it's possible that the program goes
this way it's possible that it goes this
way we just don't know which way it will
go whereas here it's the user input
decides which great so we have all of
the information from the subtraction in
the model that we go internal so this
gives a surge of this abstract quaddle
tracker that takes a program a temporal
property abstracts the program somehow
converts it to valid Kripke structure
and now can check and see whether it is
enough information through either very
far refute the property and if there
isn't enough information they will say
that the result is unknown and we need
to do refine so if you look at just that
safety properties and we can actually do
exactly the same counterexample guided
refinement since if we know that error
that whether error is reachable is not
known then we're going to get a
counterexample we're going to get an
execution that goes for all of these
transitions gets to an error state and
has it least one unknown transition
basically saying if this transition is
true then we would get to nerve this is
false and we don't get dinner so that's
why we don't know what the actual result
now we can ignore all of these
transitions whatever their values is and
just look at it as a sequence of
that's just a counterexample so we can
apply any of the standard counterexample
guided refinement it but this would only
work for safety problem as interesting
think about Kai check is that in
addition to giving you an answer it can
also produce a proof explaining how it
got to the center so for the same
example the proof would look something
like this where you would read it
bonnema basically this last line says
that we don't know whether error is
reachable from this initial state and
then it tries and provide you an
explanation what the mobile what's the
reasoning the mobile tracker one sir and
basically here it's as well in four
steps I can show you that why is there
why where the error is reachable is
unknown and that's because there is a
true transition from s0 to s1 and then
whether error is reachable from s 1 is
still not known and then there is an
unknown transition from s1 to s2 gets us
here and then we know of that promise to
error is ritual now just by following
this proof we know that well right the
way we can stop following the proof at
this point because we only carry why the
result doesn't know we don't care why we
can actually get to an error from
critical point and now if we look at
this part that we actually is then
approve you'll see that the only reason
why the weather is reachable isn't known
is because we had to use some unknown
transition does that see cause why the
result isn't known we can map it back to
our model figure out what statement with
response in abstract program mode
statement response in the complete
program and apply refinement to try and
find out well predicates to turn this
unknown transition into either jewel
so when we use this proof to guide the
refinement then only a part of a proof
has to be generated there is no need to
validate any counter examples because
unknown steps already explicitly marked
boosie no proof and since we can
generate this proof for arbitrary
properties refinement is no longer
limited to finite linear explanations
which is what allows us to do properties
other than the safety problem so this is
um
that
this is
mm-hmm
counterexample
if
so if your mobile tracker will tell you
I'm reasoning about this abstract model
and the result is unknown it can't
pinpoint you to reach fax it needs about
the model in order for this proof to be
inclusive and then you just go and
refine it but you could still rely on
counter examples if that happens to be
better for certain tangible the one does
not preclude in them and so this is a an
overview of this new framework which
combines figure with reasoning about
vulnerable structures and basically we
use this exact semantics to convert
abstract programs to Velma Kripke
scriptures take arbitrary temporal
property use KY check to decide whether
it's print false and if the result is a
known generate a proof and use this
proof to find place to refine and
generate and improve our obstruction
guru kid disposal this is a architecture
of the tool and basically starts by
parsing the program building abstracting
it by building a control flow graph and
then gaining into the slope where we
check whether property which acts the
property if the result is definitely
stop otherwise generate a partial proof
mine is for new predicate and refine the
tool itself is about thirty thousand
lines of Java and it's based on a whole
variety of third-party components in
particular we use seal to simplify
parsing of two programs we use sevilla
see light as our tier improver to figure
out what happens to each predicate and
every statement and kind shake itself is
based on Colorado University decision
diagram like so now let me show you a
few ways in which this exact semantics
can be exploited with Cindy Hsu Griffin
if we look again and how this eager
framework operate we'll see that we
constantly create one obstruction of the
program run the analysis on it if the
result is inconclusive we build the new
abstraction which looks very similar to
the previous one and then run the
analysis again
so it seems it would be very useful if
we could reuse the analysis that we done
on one obstruction when we construct the
more refined and this is actually rather
easy with exactement so here this box
represent some kind of an obstruction
whereas this is our initial state this
is our state and we want to know what
the error is rich since we use a
backward symbolic analysis then when the
analysis terminates we now not just
whether error is Richard 10 but actually
can partition this abstract state space
into three regions we know that in some
states error is reachable so this states
can actually get sooner in some states
error is unreachable and in other states
the result is inconclusive and of course
this process would continue would
continue refining until the initial
state belongs to one of this group now
because this is just a collection of
abstract state we can represent it by a
formula over the predicate that we used
in abstraction so maybe this case this
region corresponds to while air is
reachable if you're already at an error
state or the word line 10 all with line
8 and access positive access positive is
one of our pretty so now once we go and
build a more refined obstruction instead
of checking whether we can get from here
to one of our state we can change your
property and just check whether the
previously known error region is
reachable instead so this way the model
checker doesn't have to spend any time
to recompute why error is reachable from
here and only has to concentrate on how
can we get how can we make the analysis
more conclusive for the part where it
was inconclusive
so one interesting side effect of
reusing previous results is that it also
changes what counter examples are
available when we try to come up with a
refund so typically a model checker
would use the shortest counter example
for refinement so if we have this to
counter examples that go that both go to
error state the model checker would
always pick this one but if we were
using our previous results and maybe by
the time we got to this obstruction
we're actually checking whether this
error region is ritual in which case
this counter example would be the
shortest one and so this would allow us
to guide the refinement towards the most
promising counter on the counter example
then has the least number of steps until
it gets to a point from which we already
know that error is rich finally one
other interesting thing about exact
semantics is how they deal with in
precise obstruction so typically we
would really like to use the most
precise obstruction but computing site
you think is very expensive and so we
have to live with some coarse
obstructions instead if we combine this
resolver approximation then even if an
abstraction is course it's still often
sufficient to verify that error is
unreachable but refutation becomes
harder because the course is obstruction
the most pious counter example but this
is not really a problem for exact cement
here is an example here we have an
abstract program which is the best
approximation of something and it has
the single execution doesn't get to an
error state and so easy to show that
error is unreachable now if instead we
use a coarser obstruction maybe we
decided not to compute what happens to
be one here and here all this coarser
abstraction would produce more behaviors
in our approximation but as long as none
of these behaviors go to the earth day
we can still can't prove that error is
unreachable and therefore very
terrorism reachable on the concrete /
but what happens if instead we have a
program where error is actually Richard
against the same example except now
there's an this condition is negated and
so we can get to know well again we have
a single execution it goes to an error
state even in an over approximation will
find it it has to be valid execution to
the own execution of abstract program
and we terminate thank we found there
but if our abstraction is not as precise
well then this will introduce more
behaviors and the only way in over
approximating model checker can
conclusively say that error is reachable
if it can find this black violet counter
example in this whole sea of grace
perusal the refutation becomes harder
and if you look now at what happens in
exact semantics well if you make an
obstruction coarser we do get more
transitions we do get more possible
transition but as long as there is
enough information to prove that error
is reachable will have enough necessary
transitions to do so here for example
the reasoning would go as follows it's
say well first of all be 2 becomes false
then I get to this block of code and I'm
not sure when i'm going to enter the if
statement on all entries if statement
but they do know whatever happens you
choose and change and therefore by the
time i get to this point and since b 2
is false this condition is true and i'll
get you on earth this abstraction is
still enough to prove that there is in
fact regime
so to evaluate our model checker run it
on several examples that come with class
district with a blast model checker and
compared the time substitute now of
course the Ottoman blast is very
different heuristics are just comparing
time slowness and not sufficient but we
wanted to have some kind of baseline to
see what would be the acceptable
performance of a software model checker
and this become and if you look at the
time so yes I'm actually does fairly
well one thing that may look surprising
is that it needed quite a few more
predicate for this two examples then
what blaster used and the reason is that
since we found that exact semantics are
not affected might break course
obstruction and we found out that it's
better to try and add lots of predicates
during each refinement face but then do
a very very coarse obstruction I'm link
which is computationally linear in the
number of predicates and then in most in
many cases this was sufficient to get a
conclusive pinellas pan together
inclusive riddle so in summary yessum is
yet another software model checker it's
based on a combination of the seeker
framework with reasoning over bound up
Kripke structures the exact semantics of
up strict programs that it uses enable
more precise analysis which is equally
useful for true and false properties and
at the same time it doesn't seem to add
a significant computational overhead and
allow us to use previous results and
other extensions at the approved based
abstraction refinement that we use
remove the requirement of having a
linear finite counter example and
enables checking of arbitrary city of
properties if you interested in more
information on the tool it's available
on my puppy so I started by giving you a
list of some of my projects I just
wanted to kind of highlight the
relationship between them so really a
multivariate model checking is kind of
in route of many of my other projects so
I showed you how it would be used in
software model checking the reason about
this partial models
and also can be used for vacuity
detection where we want to know how well
is it probably satisfied and then this
additional values that you can have in
multivariate model checking would keep
track of which part of a formula is used
where during the analysis and it can
also be used for temporal logic you
checking where we want to try and find
propositional solutions to curious which
are made up of temporal logic formulas
and in this case again the values would
correspond to all possible solutions the
lattice of propositional formulas and
what a multivalued model checking would
do is kinda compute with this values to
come up with solution to this curve so
in terms of future work well in the long
term I plan to continue development and
integration of automated reasoning tools
for software engineering in the short
term I'm interested in developing a more
modular analysis framework which is one
of the limitations of existing software
model checking approaches and they're
typically a whole program analysis
approaches but programs are not designed
this way they designed module only and
the only way we can scale the analysis
to really large programs is to take
advantage of this during the analysis
I'm also interested in looking at
applying software model checking to
concurrent systems and one of the
reasons is because our abstractions
actually can tell the difference between
non determinism which is due to
concurrency and non determinism which is
due to something being unknown and one
of the problems there so we can do
fairly small examples of concurrent
programs but since we use control flow
graph as our initial abstraction and
makes it hard to analyze concurrent
programs since their control flow graph
by itself is quite large and finally I'm
interested in exploring a new domains
fault immediate reasoning particular I'm
interested in applying model checking
technology to reason about security and
also I'm interested in exploring
analysis of web services which on one
hand are highly distributive and highly
concurrent systems
and have a fairly complicated
communication primitive which makes them
rather hard to analyze and on the other
hand it seems like in the future most of
the programs that will actually want to
analyze would be some kind of web
service finally I want to acknowledge my
advisor and some of the graduate
students who worked with me on this
project and some of them undergraduate
students at a super race during this
time and that's it